la société socialiste a pour fondement
essentiel la propriété collective de
l'ensemble des grands moyens de
production et des changes et l'exercice
du pouvoir politique par la classe
ouvrière en alliance avec les autres
couches de la population laborieuse
or il suffit de lire le programme commun
pour constater que sa réalisation
n'équivaudrait pas à l'instauration du
socialisme en france ou ne le disons pas
pour rassurer les adversaires du
socialisme mais parce que nous sommes au
contraire soucieux de ne pas laisser
diminué rapetisser affiche affadir
l'idée du socialisme et son contenu
révolutionnaire le régime que la
réalisation du programme commun
permettrait d'instaurer c'est une
démocratie politique et économique qui
correspond à ce que nous appelons quant
à nous et sans avoir le fétichisme des
mots une démocratie avancée
c'est à dire une démocratie telle que
notre pays n'en a jamais connue et qui
se manifesterait par des réformes
politiques et économiques d'une portée
sociale sans précédent
le programme commun et d'un programme et
alice a program réalisa un programme que
nous appelons les travailleurs les
démocrates les patriotes à faire
triompher
parce qu'il fera du bonheur une idée
neuve en france